yeah it took me a while to get around to
it I really apologize for that but I
really enjoyed the first sinister movie
so I wanted to see what happens next
let's watch sinister do or rather let's
watch all the respect that sinister one
gained for the horror movie genre just
get wiped out it's pretty much what this
movie does
sinister - so sinister 2 is the sequel's
of the 1st sinister movie a horror movie
I really loved in sinister 2 there's a
mom with her two kids they're on the run
from the dickbag husband who's really
abusive and now that's this movie no
seriously that's sinister - in a
nutshell yeah there's that little
inconvenience about one of the kids goes
down to the basement and watches a bunch
of gore nose yeah you know the videos in
the first movie that was ultimately used
as a tool to show ethan hawke how the
boogeyman operated what's going on it
was revealing information to him yeah
they're kind of in this movie but in
this movie you can tell this the
directions way of going like well let me
people love them in the last movie they
were a smash hit and the last movie so
we need to have those videos in this
movie so let's just have a kid watch
them a lot that's just what he does in
the movie goes down there and the
children of the corner like watch this
movie so we watches him to like watch
another one he watches it and they're
like okay that's enough for today
rinse and repeat and that's this movie
these videos are so overly violent in
this movie they're violent for the sake
of being violent not for the sake of
giving information which is what they
should have been that was one of the
coolest things about sinister wine and
sinister one you see one of the videos
in the very beginning early oh that's
unsettling and the movie starts and at a
point in that movie he finds out that
the boogeyman was in every one of the
videos and you're like no he can't have
been in the one I saw at the very
beginning of this movie it was one still
shot I never saw subtlety like that gets
in my head and that's the difference
between sinister one - sinister -
sinister one subtle sinister - not so
subtle they start showing the boogeyman
at the beginning of the movie well there
he is ranted technically you saw him in
the beginning of the first movie but
that's the scary part is you didn't know
it holy [ __ ] what a [ __ ] snooze I
checked my watch this rumor as it has to
be wrapping on my god we're only 45
minutes in that was depressed I really
felt dread yet not from the movie but in
the fact that we were only 45 minutes
into this monstrosity let's get right to
the child actors because holy guy the
main one the movie more or less
concentrates on the one who's kind of
getting corrupted by the little bad kids
he was the best of the child actors in
this movie the rest of them I expected
at least one of them - raises an to be
like cuz somebody erased it from the
archive memory if you get the reference
Congrats you know bad child actors when
you see them and the dickbag stepdad
comes on the scene he was so
over-the-top cartoony dick foghorn
leghorn was less of a cartoony dick than
this dick and the weirdest thing in this
movie I feel like I'm gonna spoil it and
for you guys know it doesn't matter
don't you shrug this [ __ ] off is the
fact that the mom in the movie has not
seen any of the weird paranormal [ __ ]
she's not seen the little ghost kids
corrupting her case she doesn't know her
kids watching Mortal Kombat fatalities
downstairs she's seen out of it she
knows none of it the only thing she
knows that is going on or even suspects
that's going on is her husband's coming
after the kids that's it so in the end
when these invisible ghost children she
cannot say you start throwing [ __ ]
everywhere in her house she should have
been like what the [ __ ] where am I
what's happening where's my reality and
yeah kind of freaks her out but it's not
it doesn't seem like it's abnormal you
can tell is freaking her out this sense
is like oh god this again no lady you've
never do this she should have had a
heart attack out of shock because there
is no swell than horror movies like this
is usually a creaking sound then a door
slams then maybe someone might get
scratched or attack and then by the end
they're able to accept the look yeah
this is very bad and I'm freaked out but
I knew it was coming a safe might as
well fallen on her kid's head that would
have been less shocking guys in the end
I'm gonna wrap this [ __ ] up right now
sinister to has nothing that I liked
about sinister one sinister two does
nothing but taint the sinister name it's
not suspenseful it's not scary it's not
interesting it's boring a [ __ ] no other
way to say it sinister to is [ __ ]
other things I feel like a fails you
guys didn't get this review up early and
now some people may have watched the
moving a little [ __ ] I don't know man I
don't know maybe I'll go watch it I'm
sorry I failed you it will probably
happen again in life for sure but I'm
sorry it happened this time I still
sinister - have you seen this what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you